la quatrième édition du bonheur des
enfants a attiré des milliers de
visiteurs un succès qui se confirme
d'année en année il faut dire que les
équipements les agents du conseil
départemental ont pendant ces dix jours
travaillé d'arrache-pied pour faire le
bonheur des enfants mais aussi de leurs
parents d'un enfant qui va naître la
parole pourquoi les activités et à
chaque fois c'est toujours plein
le stock et la lésion précis les impôts
comme tout ce qui nous faisons les bons
japonaise les guirlandes les bourreaux
papier enfin elle a fait beaucoup de ski
pour creuser tous les enfants dont ils
ont adoré les activités là avec la
bibliothèque départementale des ateliers
différentes raisons
doré j'étais bien contente et je trouve
ça très chouette
et comme ça on veut cet atelier on
pourrait en rire un peu nos sapins des
animateurs des médiateurs qui ont créé
des objets qui ont raconté des histoires
que l'essayer avec les petits et les
grands
comme ici sur le centre du musée léon
dierx et de l'artothèque surprise oui
mais c'est surtout la famille entière
qui est qui qui est mis en cause il ya
les parents il ya les enfants il ya des
personnes âgées mais c'est vraiment
toutes catégories des publics d'accord
mais tu es vraiment étonné employés
deuxième jeu sol attire tout simplement
les enfants mais finalement des enfants
heureux qui ont profité pleinement de
toutes les activités jusqu'à la dernière
minute
tu mets les manèges non j'ai aimé le
concept c'est bien je viens danser je
vais rigoler on a fait des disques à la
côte de ger en attente de l'activité
c'est super j'ai envie de venir ici tous
les vrais que ça ça comme ça tout le
temps et c'est devant le muséum
d'histoire naturelle que le bouquet
final a ébloui les visiteurs qui ont
assisté à l'histoire des quatre saisons
né au bout mais on arrête avec ce jeu
vidéo
un début de hausse c'est toujours trop
chaud je préférerais a tenté d'entrer au
fantastique de calais c'était génial
gros lieuse magique
je crois que le bonheur des enfants va
gagner son public et que les agents du
conseil départemental ont gagné aussi la
palme d'or du savoir faire du savoir
bien accueillir donc du savoir est avec
des valeurs de nouvel an nous demande
l'annexé à travers le travail réalisé
par l'association et les agents du
conseil général sur le bois de goyavier
à travers aussi les animations les
ateliers ludiques pédagogiques de la
bibliothèque départementale à travers
également les rendez vous j'ai envie de
dire trimestriels que le les musées faut
pour accueillir des publics en essayant
de changer la problématique en essayant
de montrer de manière pédagogique de
manière informative toutes les richesses
de nous avons ici chez nous mais rui un
rendez vous incontournable pour le
conseil général et je crois que les
familles des parents les adultes comme
les enfants
il attend avec beaucoup d'impatience que
l'opération revenait à des enfants
s'anime
rendez vous l'année prochaine sur le
thème désastre pour avoir encore plus la
tête dans les étoiles et le mot de la
fin sera pour tous ces enfants qui
attendent chaque année le père noël qui
pendant dix jours à transformer le
jardin de l'état en un pays magique
raillé noël à tous